طبعا خبز التنور بالبدايه او كلمه التنور
او التنور هي كلمه ذات اصول ارمنيه وتركيه
والبعض يقول انه هي ذات اصول فارسيه يعني
تعددت ال- ال-
الاحاديث حول هذه الكلمات لكن التنور يقال
انه وجد في العصر البابلي الاول في العراق
والبعض يقول انه وجد قبل الاف السنين في
الموصل عاده العمل على التنور همم يكون
اغلى غالبا في البلدان التي تقع على مقربه
من الانهار مثل بلاد الشام والعراق وغيرها
همم وفي العراق على وجه الخصوص اشتهر خبز
التنور او اشتهرت النور الطين انه العراق
بلد عرف بصناعه الفخار منذ الاف السنين
همم وبعدها تطول طبعا التنور واصبح تنور
معدني مثل ما نشوف اليوم واا اكثر
العاملين على التنورهما النساء في العراق
ولهذا اليوم احنا ظهرنا مع الشيف افتخار
اهلا وسهلا
ليش
تنور او حتى النور بالنساء ودائما
العراقيين يقولون انه المراه اللي تعمل
على التنور هي عمرها نادره شو معنى يعني
همم تعرفينا الوضع العائله ما يسمح انه
مثلا دائما تشتري صمون او خبز لذلك لازم
تكون ربه البيت انه تخبز ان احنا ذلك
نسميها نادره اللي تعرف تخبز نقول عليها
نادره
بس تعرفين همم متى طلبات العائله يعني
خصوصا العوائل الكبار يعني لازم يخبزون
بالبيت طبعا
خبز التنور والعمل على التنور ارتبط به
الوضع الاقتصادي والازمات الاقتصاديه لعشر
العراقيين على مر العصور خاصه في ثمانينات
القرن الماضي في العراق اكو شارع همم يعني
شارع معروف لا زال اسمه حتى الان شر على
الخبازات توقف عمل للنساء عاليه في عام
2003 لكن قبل 2003 وخاصه في ثمانينات
القرن الماضي حين كان الرجال يعني في
الحروف القتال كانت النساء هناك تعمل على
هات الخبز وبيعه همم خبز التنور طبعا
المعروف
يعني هلا بس نفهم منك انه يعني رغم انه
هذه كانت جزء من طاقه
ونصف بس بدي انا افهم شغله انه هل قال له
النوادر
يعني ناس
خلينا نسال سته افتخار خلينا نسال سته
افتخار لانها عاش عاش
عاشت التنور في السابق ولا الوقت الحالي
النساء التي عملنا حتى تنوره
تحدي همم صار على الكهرباء وانت قاعده على
الغاز وانت قاعده يعني مو مثل هسه او مو
مثل قبل الطين بس اتحدث بالعكس هوايه
عمل يعني
تقدمين فطائر مثلا هذا الخبز هذا طبعا هذا
نوع من الخبز يسموه بالعراقي خبز هو يكون
خليط من الخضره واللحم
والعجينه يعني
حدثينا عن الانواع اللي تقدميها انتم شلون
طورتيها بالخبز
انا عندي بالبيت كل شيء يحبون الخبز وهذه
الشغلات
دائما احاول اجدد لهم بها يعني انوع لهم
فهذه الفطائر مثلا اللحمه بعجين نتعرف
عليك تعرفين بره انه كل خبزوه بالفرن ال-
همم الحجري مثل مال الصمون انا خبزه
بالتنور طيب طبعا العراقيين ايضا كانوا
يعني ينظرون الخبز بالتنور الى الاله
سابقا وهذا التقليد يعني يمكن لا زال مو
لازم لبعض العراقيين طبعا يا ناس يعني
فعلا ابتعتونا بهذه الفقره سواء من
المعلومات او حتى مشاهده هذا التنور يخبز
على نار هادئه ويعيدنا الى ايام جميله ما
زال هناك الزمن الجميل
على الفطور احنا رح نشوفك قريبا ان شاء
الله بتعزمينا وبنعزمك شكرا جزيلا زينب
المشاط ضايفتها شيف افتخار معموري